et ainsi le 29 juin 1949 le
téléspectateur peut assister à la
première édition du journal télévisé
fondateur directeur rédacteur en chef
pierre sabbagh
comme je me souvenais de cette histoire
de ballon à la radio je voulais vraiment
le faire pour pour l'image et ça a été
le premier reportage du journal le 29
juin 1949 avec michel zinkievich comme
caméraman dans une nacelle nous étions
quatre et ça s'est pas très bien passé
il y avait beaucoup de vent
il ya 40 km de paris environ il ya eu un
courant d'air froid on a été aspiré vers
le sol on a lâché du lest du simple un
peu trop tard sans doute
c'est alors qui est apparu dans un champ
absolument nu un pommier genève fera
deux camps n'avaient naturellement n'y a
eu droit pour très vite très vite avec
la nacelle on l'a cassée est ce qu'on
avait pas tellement vu mais des
hurlements nous l'ont appris très vite
c'est une ligne à haute tension
mais les grands les hôtes les ford je ne
sais pas quel est le voltage qui passe
là-dedans mais cette importance et là on
a buté avec le ballon lui même cette
fois heureusement ce n'était pas les
bons hommes le ballon à habiter une fois
deux fois deuxième fois il ya eu un art
merveilleux mais alors qu'est l'orage on
a déclenché et puis la troisième fois
il ya une déchirure dans le vallon le
gaz s'est échappé sur étincelles s'est
enflammé alors qu'est-ce 15 cents mètres
cubes de gaz qui brûle ça fait un très
beau chalumeau les poteaux en ciment
était resté on a arrêté les trains dans
la région
enfin de couper le courant partout une
véritable catastrophe nationale comme
vous voyez premier journal et michel
d'activité ne pas lâcher sa caméra
étonnant il ya une poignée d'amis après
censé surveiller pour savoir ce qu'ils
souhaiteraient le premier celui qui ne
souhaiteraient pas pour pas que les
autres non oui bien entendu
je prends un mètre cinquante de mètres
du sol les cats ont sauté vraiment et
michel n'a pas lâché sa caméra il s'est
écarté du ballon il a fait 1 110 on
arrive à vu arriver les gendarmes pour
nous emmener en prison parce que
qu'est-ce que c'est l'excès rigolo
télévision que je te soutiens rien enfin
le journal tv alors inexistant ça
n'existait absolument pas et on en a
parlé je me souviens lendemain dans la
presse et j'ai même été accusée d'avoir
pris mon briquet et d'avoir fumé ma pipe
comme il rien se passer dans l'arche des
mapic d'acheminer de garde pour
provoquer leur provoqué l'événement ont
fabriqué l'événement un bien non pas du
tout
[Musique]